hi guys this is Rob from simply learn
and today we're going to look at three
very important data related roles in the
field of data science and then we're
going to pit them against each other so
welcome to data scientist versus data
analyst versus data engineer now let's
have a look at what's in store for you
firstly we will talk about the job
descriptions the skill sets required for
each role the salary roles and
responsibilities and the companies
hiring for these positions so now let's
have a look at each of these roles in
detail first off let's have a look at
data scientist now a data scientist is
able to create machine learning based
tools or processes within the company
now they use advanced data techniques
such as clustering division trees neural
networks and so on so that they can
derive business conclusions they are the
senior most member in the team which
involves a data engineer as well as a
data analyst now they need to have
in-depth knowledge of statistics data
handling and machine learning they also
take inputs from data engineers as well
as analysts so that they can formulate
actionable insights for the business now
data scientists also needs to have the
same skills as a data analyst and an
engineer but needs to have a lot more
in-depth knowledge and expertise with
these skills next up we have data
analyst now data analyst is someone who
is able to translate numeric data into a
form that everyone in the organization
can understand now this is an
entry-level position in the data
analytics team he or she needs to have
technical skills in programming
languages such as Python and have
knowledge of tools like Excel and
understand the basics of data handling
modeling and reporting now in due time
they can move up the ranks by taking up
roles of data engineer and data
scientist with some experience that they
can accumulate over the years and
finally we have DITA engineer our data
engineer is someone who's involved with
pairing data who's involved with
preparing data for analytical or
operational purposes now they are the
intermediary between the data analyst
and the data scientist he or she needs
to have a lot of experience when it
comes to developing constructing and
maintaining architectures now they do
generally work on big data and submit
their reports to the data scientist so
that they can be analyzed now let's have
a look at the skill sets required for
each of these roles first off we have
data scientist now since this role is a
little more coding oriented
need to know a great deal when it comes
to programming languages programming
languages such as Python our SQL SAS
Java and so on now you also need to be
well-versed with frameworks in relations
to big data such as big spoken do
peaking of a do if you want to learn
more about how it works
I suggest you click on the top right
corner and watch our video on what to do
coming back data scientists also need to
be well versed with machine learning
deep learning and other similar
technologies next up we have data
analyst now this role is much less
technical as compared to a data
scientist as well as a data engineer
considering how its entry-level here
knowing programming languages is a great
bonus so an idea about programming
languages such as Python or SQL
javascript SSAS and so on is a great
benefit at the same time you do need to
be well-versed with tools such as SAS
miner Microsoft Excel s SAS SPSS and so
on and finally we have data engineer now
being a data engineer requires you to be
well versed with a bunch of programming
languages as well as frameworks now you
need to know about programming languages
such as Python our SQL SAS Java and so
on while having expertise in frameworks
such as hadoop mapreduce hive big apache
spark data streaming no SQL and so on
now let's talk about money or the salary
each of these roles get firstly we have
the data scientists who answer whopping
137 thousand US dollars per annum then
we have the data analyst 267 thousand
dollars per annum which is a pretty high
salary when you consider that it's only
an intern at the job and a data engineer
which is in the median with a hundred
and sixteen thousand US dollars per
annum now let's talk about roles and
responsibilities firstly we have the
data scientist now the data scientist
gets to work with a lot of unstructured
data so they need to mine and clean the
data so that it's usable they need to be
able to design machine learning models
to work on the Big Data they need to
infer and interpret the analysis on big
data to be able to lead an entire team
to achieve the goals of the organization
and deliver conclusions that have a
direct business impact now let's have a
look at the roles and responsibilities
of a data analyst they need to use
queries to gather information from a
database they need to process the data
and provide summary reports they need to
use basic algorithms for their work such
as linear regression logistic
rushon and so on and have core skills in
statistics data munging data
visualization and exploratory data
analysis and finally we have data
engineer now they need to mine through
the data so that they can gain insights
from it they need to convert erroneous
data into a useable form so that they
can be further analyzed they need to
write queries on data they need to
maintain the design as well as
architecture of the data and create
large data warehouses using ETL or
extract transform node now let's have a
look at some of the companies hiring for
this role firstly for data scientists
you have Citibank
Facebook Schneider Intel Amazon and so
on for data unless you have enforces
rockin these are capital one Walmart and
so on and for data engineer you have
google cisco flow kosgeb descend apple
spotify and much much more so if all
this is inspired you to get started with
data science I suggest you take simply
learn certification now I'm choosing
this certification because it acts as
great entry point for starting your
career as a data analyst or a data
engineer now with this certification it
goes through all the important concepts
when it comes to data science and has 68
hours of in-depth learning for e.l.f
industry based projects interactive
learning with Jupiter notebooks and
dedicated mentoring sessions from our
faculty of industry experts now some of
the concepts are you'll be going through
statistical analysis and business
applications Python environment setup
mathematical computing with Python which
is numpy SCI pi data manipulation with
pandas machine learning with
scikit-learn and so much more so then
you can start up on your step to
becoming a data and list a data engineer
and then eventually a data scientist now
if you're already working as a data
analyst or a data engineer you can
become a certified data scientist which
simply learns data scientist master's
program this goes through all the
important concepts that you need to know
so that you can become a successful as
well as certified data scientist and
with that we've reached the end of this
video I hope this has inspired you to
get certified and get ahead in your
career thank you for watching and stay
tuned for more from simpler
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here